wow this is what i've been missing
twilight was a cringe fest for a lot of
the actors from awkward love scenes to
literal paper cuts in the eye and
freezing cold filming conditions it was
no walk in the park unless that park was
in forks washington we're looking at the
scenes that were just downright painful
to film
i spent so much time just infuriated
number one paper cuts our literal worst
fear well the twilight snow was made of
many things and one of those things
happened to be paper paper snow plus
golden vampire contacts equals pain
apparently and elizabeth reeser got tiny
bits of paper snow stuck under her
colored contacts her eyes were swollen
shut the next day ugh nightmare fuel
yeah i mean it was described to me as a
horror story number two a stake in the
foot should have been enough to take
vampire bella down while filming some
reshoots for the first hunt scene in
breaking dawn part 2 kristen stewart
managed to puncture her foot the reason
for the reshoots they all loved the
hunting scenes and she wanted to do a
good job of it stewart admitted we all
wanted more of it number three one
crooked thumbs up for this mistake
kristen stewart broke her thumb filming
her first scene as a vampire she'd
stated i'd been on the sidelines for so
long just itching so i was bursting to
do it which is probably why i broke my
thumb i was a little overzealous between
a hole in the foot and a broken thumb
it's starting to sound like vampires are
daintier than humans makes perfect sense
have you seen all those sparkles we were
able to really get close to every well
to most experiences that she has number
four pattinson has been very vocal about
twilight being a pain in the butt to
film robert pattinson had a much less
noticeable injury but it was definitely
noticeable to him the poor guy injured
his booty they were doing the fight
scene at the end of the first movie and
he nearly tore his glute they had to get
a physiotherapist to come in and massage
his butt cheek for the rest of the day
hopefully the physiotherapist wasn't
team edward
i think he'll be just fine
number five jackson rathbone experienced
the true wrath of the rib bone during
the filming of breaking dawn rathbone
did all of his stunts with a broken rib
i didn't even tell the production
company because i was afraid they were
gonna you know not let me do my own
stunts and i had to do it so number six
filming in the freezing cold rain is
fine for a werewolf but not so fine for
an actor for taylor lautner the scene
where bella first sees jacob after his
transformation was the worst of all he
said we're standing on that little hill
right behind jacob's house and it was 35
degrees and it was pouring rain on top
of us they filmed the scene all day
as soon as cut was called he and stewart
would run over to a heater and get
wrapped in blankets they'd get two
minutes and then they'd have to do it
all again
lautner said i just had to take myself
to another world so during the scene i
wasn't sitting there shivering it's
challenging
i like challenges so i i like it number
seven honestly gnawing a hole in
somebody's stomach would be weird robert
pattinson laughed himself to tears over
trying to tear the vampire baby out of
bella with his teeth there was one shot
where he had to look directly into the
camera and he was crying with laughter
he admitted i was stopping tears from
coming out of my eyes and it looks like
i'm crying in the thing and i'm not
supposed to be able to cry as a vampire
number 8 team jacob gains a point after
this one the last day of shooting the
tent scene kristen stewart had the
stomach flu and was vomiting between
takes betcha couldn't picture that
happening in a post-covid world huh
stephanie meyer admitted it was taylor
lautner who was taking the most care of
kristen she stated and taylor like he
was over digging around grabbing a
garbage can i'm like why is taylor
taking the garbage number 9 taylor
lautner was sad over twilight ending the
wedding scene was his last scene and
he'd said that won't go away at all uh
you know it'll be more difficult he was
overwhelmed with emotion after it was
over taylor and kristen just looked at
each other not really having much to say
i'm looking forward to like that next
chapter in life number ten at least the
team considered a rig it's too bad it
didn't work taylor lautner had to carry
kristen stewart for an entire day down a
dirt path after the rig they designed to
do it just didn't look natural on screen
luckily taylor stepped in but he
definitely regretted it after a few
takes it was uncomfortable for me i mean
it's it's always uncomfortable number
eleven crying sweating injuries sounds
like being human is way more comfortable
the vampire intimate scenes were agony
for both stuart and pattinson pattinson
was a sweaty vampire which is
technically impossible and he was
literally trying to stop sweat from
hitting kristen's back i have absolutely
no idea how to do it number 12 rain rain
go away anna kendricks not happy taylor
lautner wasn't the only one suffering in
the rain kendrick joked that filming
twilight was like a hostage situation
because of how awful the weather was i
just remember being so cold and
miserable she just recalls her converse
being completely soaked through she
enjoyed working with the cast though it
was just that oregon weather that had
her struggling to stay enthusiastic
filming twilight definitely had its
challenges huh it isn't the easiest
movie to just do and take seriously
we're looking at you our pats for all
that corpsing
a fitting phrase for an actor playing a
vampire no what injury made you cringe
the most let us know in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things